you dropped out of school because all  you wanted to do was to learn how to  make movies yeah that seems to me the  only way to go you know I mean film  school was never an option it just it  seems to me to be a waste of time and a  waste of money there's a scary mentality  I think in film schools my small sort of  dealing with them is is is something  that's really terrifying I walked into a  film class and what about screenwriting  and this guy the first the opening line  was you know if you're here to write  Terminator 2 just leave now I'll be back  and I thought well that's terrible  there's it could be a kid in the corner  there that wants to write Terminator too  that's his vision that's his movie  that's what he likes let him do it you  know you know my my film education  really came from watching other movies  you know